So Donald Trump's press briefings in general
have become completely beyond parody.
They often start fifteen, 30, 45, 60, 70 minutes
late.
Never with an explanation.
Completely disrespectful to members of the
press and to to to the audience, quite frankly.
And that's sort of part and parcel of how
we've observed Donald Trump behave his entire
presidency.
Yesterday, Donald Trump held one of these
press briefings outside the White House.
I guess because it was a nice day and he made
no sense and he said outrageously crazy things
that should serve to remind us every single
day, every single one of us, that he has to
go.
He must go.
It's time.
Let's look at some of the completely humiliating
and depraved moments.
Donald Trump, first of all, furious that people
were wearing masks.
Donald Trump demanded that Jeff Mason take
off his mask before he would accept a question
from Jeff President.
The issue of what happens when you're afraid
you're gonna have to take that office, just
you can take it off your house.
How many feet of your way?
Well, if you don't take it off, you're very
muffled.
So if you would take.
That would be a lot easier.
I'd just be a lot lighter.
It's better.
Yeah, it's better.
Mr President, Trump does not like those masks.
Remember, no one at his huge rally last week
in Latrobe, Pennsylvania, was wearing a mask.
Trump doing another rally tonight.
Will there be masks?
Reportedly not later.
One reporter did actually pull his mask down
or off before asking a question.
Trump praised him for not wearing a mask for
you.
He sounded so clear as opposed to everybody
else.
They refuse your tweets about the 16 19 David
Pakman.
What a great leader.
Right.
Lee really leading by example during a pandemic,
criticizing those wearing masks and praising
those not wearing masks.
And so after we got past the mask, triggering
Donald Trump, again, talking about all of
the crimes that Barack Obama and Joe Biden
supposedly committed against him.
USA Today, questions about the Durham report
that you have talked about recently.
So let's see what happens now.
You've accused people of committing crimes
against you during the Russian investigation,
and they spied on my campaign.
That's right, Mike.
Where they spotted my campaign.
And if they were Democrats, they would have
been in jail two years ago.
They would have been in jail literally, if
this side were the Democrats said they would
have been in jail two years ago for 50 year
terms for treason and other things.
My question is, do you want the Justice Department
to indict people over this?
I'm not going to say that I have to see the
report.
I haven't seen I purposely.
I don't know.
That was a good thing.
Smart thing.
I don't know.
But nobody can complain about it.
I have every right to have been very much
involved.
And maybe someday I'll get involved in it.
They spied on my campaign.
And that includes Biden and Obama.
Now, remember that we're still waiting on
exactly which laws Barack Obama broke.
Which crimes the Joe Biden commit.
But in the meantime, Trump believes that 50
years in prison for each of them.
Obama and Biden would be right.
This is crazy.
This is even crazier than Trump saying to
Hillary during the debates in 2016.
You'd be locked up if I were president.
A ton of questions during yesterday's press
press briefing related to, of course, this
blockbuster story about Donald Trump allegedly
referring to troops who died in combat as
losers and suckers.
Trump denied reports that it was his choice
not to visit a military cemetery in France.
Is that we had the worst weather.
I think it was as bad a rain as I've just
about ever seen.
And it was a fog you literally couldn't see.
I walked out.
I didn't have I didn't need somebody to tell
me.
I walked out.
I said, there's no way we can take helicopters
in this.
I understand helicopters very well.
And they said, no, sir, that's been canceled.
They would have had to go Secret Service.
I have the whole list.
They would have had to go through a very,
very busy section during the day of Paris.
They would have had to go through the city.
Yeah.
Now, of course, this story already widely
corroborated, abundantly clear that it tracks
with what Donald Trump was willing to say
publicly and had been saying publicly for
years, including about John McCain.
And then again, Donald Trump denies reports
that he disparaged fallen U.S. troops.
And it's a disgrace who would say a thing
like that?
Only an animal would say a thing like that.
There is nobody that has more respect for
not only our military, but for people that
gave their lives in the military.
There's nobody and I think John Kelly knows
that.
I think he would know that.
I think he knows that from me.
Remember, Trump publicly said about John McCain.
He prefers soldiers who don't get captured.
And the topic of John McCain actually came
up.
And Trump, if you can imagine this, said he
should be praised.
Trump demanding credit for not ruining John
McCain's funeral, believing your denial of
the Atlantic story because of what you said
about John McCain in the past.
Do you understand that?
And how do you ask?
No, I don't understand.
Have you asked John Kelly for that story?
No, I don't understand it at all now because
I've always been on the opposite side of John
McCain.
John McCain like wars.
I will be a better warrior than anybody.
But when we fight a war, we're going to win
them.
And frankly, I was never a fan of John McCain,
you know, that.
I've spent very obvious.
I was.
But I had to approve his entire funeral.
I wanted him to get.
He deserved a first question or always approved
by me.
We send Air Force One to pick up the casket.
A lot of things.
But now I was not a fan of John McCain.
See, guys, none of it can be true because
Trump didn't ruin John McCain's furin funeral.
And he could have.
Trump could have ruined John McCain's funeral
and he didn't do it.
Trump then going on to say.
That his most sophisticated friends, by the
way, who are Trump's sophisticated friends,
trump sophisticated friends, said to him he
must be the most innocent person ever to be
president, be the most innocent, honorable
man ever to hold the office of president.
Think of it.
They spent just Muehler alone.
He's spent, I guess the real number turned
out to be 48 million dollars.
But whatever it was, many, many millions of
dollars, they had 18 angry Democrats looking.
They had FBI agents all over the place.
They had every and they'd have no collusion.
Friends of mine have said sophisticated friends
have said you've got to be the most innocent
guy ever to hold this office.
And there's a lot of trust to that.
Yeah.
Thank you, Mr. President.
David Pakman Donald Trump genuinely seems
to believe that he is completely innocent.
I have gone back, back and forth about this
over time.
I actually believe Trump is so delusional
that he really does think he's done nothing
wrong ever and that there is some kind of
witch hunt against him.
I used to think maybe Trump was just saying
it.
I now believe Trump actually believes it.
Confirming his total disconnect from reality.
And then Donald Trump asked about his postmaster
general, Lewis Dejoy.
There are now multiple investigations into
Lewis Dejoy.
There is speculation that Lewis Dejoy has
committed multiple crimes.
And Donald Trump just plays dumb and says
he hasn't really heard too much about it.
Mr. President, if proven true, are you OK
with Postmaster General Dejoy and the fact
that he asked former employees at his private
company to make donations to the GOP and then
reimburse them?
Are you okay?
I don't know too much about it.
I read something this morning, but I don't.
Other than that, I have to say it is very
respected man.
He was approved very much by both parties.
I guess it was sort of an approval that took
place by both parties.
I don't know exactly what the story is.
I'll certainly know within a short period
of time.
I just read it for the first time.
I read it this morning, just like you did.
If you support an investigation, sir.
Sure, sure.
I think let the investigations go.
But but he's a very respected man.
Again, it was a bipartisan commission.
Postmaster general's appointed by a bipartisan
commission.
And we'll see how that goes.
But no, I think he's a very honest guy.
But we'll see less.
Trump never seems to have heard about anything
that might be bad for him.
And then lastly, Donald Trump wrapping up
with casual xenophobia, as I like to call
it, after not directly answering a single
question.
Well, I want to thank you all.
And I just want to wish you a very happy Labor
Day.
And we're having tremendous success, whether
it's on the vaccines, whether it's on the
pandemic, the plague that came in from China
that China should and never let happen, because
I will never feel the same about China.
And I just want to again, wish you a happy
Labor Day.
Thank you very much.
So, again, are these benefiting Trump?
Does Trump benefit from doing these press
briefings or is it just doing more self-inflicted
damage?
I don't know how many Trump is.
Watch this stuff.
Political observers watch it, but they're
already mostly decided.
I don't think any votes are changing as a
result of that.
Media outlets cover the highlights.
But are these really helping Trump in any
way?
That's what I want to hear from you about.
We'll have more clips and coverage of this
press briefing and tonight's rally.
By the way, that Donald Trump will be doing
on our Instagram page at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following us there and make
sure you're following me at David Pakman
as well.